when we talk about the big social
movements of the early 19th century in
the United States you can't deny that
the emergence of jacksonian democracy is
one of the most influential aspects of
early 19th century culture so what was
jacksonian democracy and why do we care
so much about it well I want to make the
argument to you that jacksonian
democracy was really the birth of modern
American political culture and by that I
mean that during this time lots of
practices emerged that are still with us
today
for example the two-party system the
spoils system even some aspects of
American political character that are
still with us today emerged in this time
period and by that I mean the kinds of
traits that we like to see in our
politicians to consider them electable
so in this series on jacksonian
democracy I'm gonna take you on a
journey from the earlier American
political culture some of the major
changes that came about in the
Jacksonian period and then just discuss
some of the ways that this still
influences us today all right so if
jacksonian democracy was a new thing
what came before it I'm a very early era
of American political life and I'm
talking here from approximately 1792
about 1820 American politics was very
aristocratic you know there were a
couple of families that tended to
dominate politics the Adams family for
example George Washington Thomas
Jefferson and these men were kind of
considered to be maybe a higher
character of man they were the
quintessential citizens of a republic
and along with that came you know a
certain amount of wealth and status and
education you know in between George
Washington and Andrew Jackson every
single person who served as president
had a college degree many of them were
Virginians and particularly Virginian
planters you see a lot of Virginians and
a lot of people from Massachusetts and
the the first couple of years of the
Republic and many of them kind of shared
a concern that there could be too much
democracy shall we say that even though
the United States was a democracy
many of the founders of the United
States worried about the tyranny of the
majority the tyranny of the mob that
they had set up this democratic
experiment where many people could vote
but they were afraid of having just too
many people voting because they looked
down on lower classes of society in that
time period they they worried that if
you didn't have a stake in the country
usually shown by property ownership
either in terms of land or in terms of
wealth then you wouldn't have the proper
investment in the fate of the nation in
order to make a rational decision about
what sort of policies should be enacted
so in the early years in the United
States many states had voting laws that
restricted the franchise to just
propertied men so really a quite small
proportion of the overall population
united states could vote interestingly
this actually meant that in some
northern states both free people of
color free black men and women could
vote
because they met the requirements for
property ownership but in the early
1800s eighteen tens these ideals of
democracy began to catch on more and
more among the common people and as new
states joined the Union like Ohio and
Illinois they came in with state
constitutions saying that all white male
citizens could vote regardless of
whether or not they owned property or
they pay taxes so in this time period
white male citizenship became associated
with voting and some of the other states
began to rewrite their state
constitutions to grant the vote to all
white males and it probably won't
surprise you that when they rewrote
those laws they managed to take out that
little loophole for free people of color
and women with certain amounts of
property so by the end of this period in
the 1850s all property requirements for
voting had been eliminated and any white
male above the age of 21 in the United
States had the right to vote and we'll
get to what that meant for American
politics in the next video